[Musik]
b 26 davon wenn man aber bin ich hoffe
meine sehr schön ab 520
vor sieben jahren verunfallt christian
wenk mit seinem rennvelo schwer doch er
wehrt arzt obwohl er nicht mehr gehen
kann
und er spielt konzert reif klavier auch
wenn er nicht frei aufrecht sitzen kann
[Musik]
zudem ist der spitzentrainer obschon der
unfall seiner sportlichen karriere ein
jähes ende zu setzen schien ein einblick
in das leben eines mannes in dessen
vokabular das wort aufgeben nicht
existiert
[Musik]
in wenigen stunden fährt christian wenk
für drei wochen nach sardinien nicht in
die ferien sondern als cheftrainer des
handbike nationalteams er wird dort
seine sportler auf die paralympics in
peking vorbereiten
christian ist von der brust abwärts
gelähmt wähle einen gegenstand hoch
heben muss er sich mit der anderen hand
festhalten
er macht dies so perfekt dass man es
fast nicht wahrnimmt
[Musik]
sven
matthias ruhiger begleitet christian auf
der langen fahrt nach sardinien er sitzt
schon seit 16 jahren im rollstuhl
so
lägen bei quere
kommen aber dann ist das schon was
besonderes
aus
jetzt ist es besser
ist in windeseile pakt für dich zu
entlocken hätte noch nicht fertig fertig
interessant
waren zwar durch unterwegs bin
relaxed und vorfreude für das training
ich war immer das hauptziel gemacht
selber vor weiterem spardruck und vor
allem im hinblick auf olympia in peking
jetzt mit der mit athleten dass das
trend ist allerdings fehl
[Musik]
und los geht's rund fünf stunden dauert
die fahrt bis nach klima dem ersten
etappenziel christian die
geschwindigkeit vom sport her gewohnt
benötigt dafür vier stunden
[Musik]
in der nähe von zürich ist christian
aufgewachsen seine eltern wohnen noch
immer da und schwelgen in erinnerungen
die mutter ist hausfrau der vater eth
professor
christian ist bereits als kind
vielseitig interessiert und er will der
beste sein was auch immer er macht
[Musik]
im jahr 2000 des christian auf dem
höhepunkt seiner karriere als dort lädt
und gehört nach seinem ersten
weltcup-sieg als wm-vierter zur welt
elite
[Musik]
dann im september 2000 verunfallt
christian während des rad trainings bei
der vorbereitung zum weltcup rennen in
japan schwer wird lebensgefährlich
verletzt und er realisiert sofort dass
er nie mehr gehen kann
stehen sieht foto kofer heizwerke von
kondomen xe vor sehr schnell betonungen
und paulus lieberman treffen ab stellt
sie ist und
gute hervor der schule fertig stellt der
parkplatz nicht beachtet auf der anderen
seite und hat trotz abgestellt zum zu
moderat stellt was ich konnte bewundert
kurzem so uns gedanken
spontan immer wieder opfer und ist das
telefon das erste
also betreuer vor ihm hat uns alle tief
soll ein spittaler legte welt sind keine
ursache aber ihnen komme dann wirklich
denke ich der nummer parker und da hat
er zu mir gesagt
ich
hab' ich bin technisch klemmt und
da sony gehört hat war für mich wichtig
mich ladner und erlaubt
wir haben dir denn unsere koffer packten
nach japan wo welle zu heben und den
hattrick poker auch gesagt naja blieben
in zürich commlab antiquierter für die
nach japan kommt ja ja ja so ganz sich
das nicht gesehen
hat sich sofort am nächsten tag kann ich
glaube dass michael die zebrafinken und
am nächsten tag telefoniert
basement nico
okay die topzeit
nächsten tage sind bedeutend schlechter
gegangen also wieder viele stellt
und den händen
seiner kräfte für nachher
nico
denn ist die ganze sache mit dem
trägerflugzeug max schautzer 1 zu mir
denn kein land nötig um maxi was den
sowieso schon eine stelle im ausschnitt
transport vereinigung mir hatte dort
könne mit fliege und
deine an ihn oder zum christian gesagt
ja und wenn niemand wunsch hätte gesagt
denke immer ist das wetter
und doch wartet
umso schöner rechts erlebnis war noch
reger zentrale gesehen in cotta und
daher gehörig und deutschland hin zum
luxus kamera
rissen alle
kraft nur noch christian
bales und
christians lebens und leistungswille
bleibt auch nach dem unfall ungebremst
nach einer rekordverdächtig kurzen
rehabilitation von zweieinhalb monaten
beendete er sein medizinstudium vom
rollstuhl aus
kaum kann er wieder gerade sitzen
perfektionierte er sein klavierspiel
und auch dem spitzensport bleibt er treu
zuerst als präsident des tri club
zofingen als organisator des intervall
duathlons und heute als cheftrainer des
handbike nationalteams
christian kommt in genua an die fahrer
auf der fähre nach sardinien dauert eine
ganze nacht lang
hier auf der fähre trifft christian
erstmals auf den rest seiner
trainingsgruppe
[Musik]
mit christian zusammen sind das sieben
sportler im rollstuhl 7 rollstühle aus
marl kein einfaches unterfangen für eine
faire gesellschaft
jetzt drücken
die sich ja nur ich habe es ja so dass
das angetan
tritt der steuer komme ich nicht
märz andauert
es fehlt ein bett in einer rollstuhl
gängigen kabine so bleibt für christian
der versuch in einer regulären engen
kabine unterzukommen
si
ins wc allerdings passt der rollstuhl
nicht rein erstens hatte seinen stufe 2
ist es zu eng
[Musik]
doch für christian gibt es immer eine
lösung im notfall rutschte er auf dem
hosenboden rein oder dann raster in die
rollstuhl gängige kabine seiner kollegen
[Musik]
schließlich sind alle in einer kabine
untergekommen und können sich bei einem
schlummertrunk aufs trainingslager
einstimmen
[Musik]
bald geht es ernst für trainer christian
er weiß nicht was ihn alles erwartet auf
sardinien freut sich aber darauf
nach einer weiteren stunde autofahrt
kommen sie in der hotelanlage auf
sardinien an das trainingsteam besteht
aus lauter nennen einige von ihnen leben
daheim in einer festen beziehung so auch
christian
hier in zürich hat christian seit seinem
unfall gelegt um mit seiner freundin
jacqueline zusammen zu ziehen hat der
letzten dezember seine single wohnung
aufgelöst jacqueline deren schwester und
christians eltern helfen ihm beim umzug
[Musik]
wie ich das mit der sammelklage beim
rollstuhl ist
das
[Musik]
vorstelle was ich denn erwischt
eigentlich ja eigentlich liegt also
drückte hauptsache nach vorn rücken
konnte nichts darauf geachtet zum
beispiel den jetzigen
niveau nicht und ich möchte
die sache im auto liegen
ohne funktionierende rumpfmuskulatur
kann sich christian nur mit hilfe seiner
arme aus dieser position wieder
aufrichten
das ist denn da spielen die
sache gekommen
ich habe gemacht
[Applaus]
sind jetzt da ganz viel bild run auf eur
womit bringen womöglich die frühe
wettkampfzeit was gott unter druck ich
freue mich werden bildlich gesehen aber
mehr innere grund für die veränderte
weil es ist teil von ihm ab das
kombinierte und ich glaube das war uns
zu wenig bewusst sind dass schluss von
aber blieb daher notwendig und weil man
immer nur für ihre leute nach den blick
dann am schluss doch nicht und darum
sind für mich ganz schön im moment aber
trotzdem entschied der letzte audi bild
alle mit rufzeichen
dass wir
hier in der nähe von luzern wohnt
christian seit anfang jahr mit
jacqueline zusammen auch da in einer
ganz normalen nicht speziell für
rollstühle gebauten wohnen
[Musik]
ich behaupte ich an die behinderung
akzeptiert also
ich
find's toll oder aber das hat ja nicht
mit raab selbst so akzeptanz der episode
mit dem rational mit dem rationalen ich
glaube ich und ich sehe ich dass es so
ist und ich war relativ ein starker
glaube daran dass es
alles was mir passiert im leben hat zum
in apolda zurückkehre
da muss ich seine hinterfrage oder warum
folgen wenn auch nicht mehr in antwort
mir im umgang mit der ganzen geschichte
einfach und sehr emotional also ich
habe einen grünen der ausdruck teil also
meistens bin ich dabei und dann
womöglich oder sich vielleicht einmal
activity und aids und den weiß ragow ist
ein moment also fisch ist die zeit aber
dennis tost und dann ist wieder
vergessen wenn ich gut also
das konzept
das hinter jetzt irgendwie aber control
stuttgart wenn ich steckte rohstoffen
und scheiße oder was wenig gekommen sie
warten wohl streichen den rivalen
durchstieg istrien also ins alte fahrrad
dass es gibt situationen wo einfach blöd
sind und dann ja
[Musik]
peter honig sie richtig dass in sachen
erreicht braucht oder nur gut wenn der
minister dass die ewig truppe stimmt im
rausch gespielt
zum beispiel wie gläser oder brauche
wohlstand ist relativ weit oben
ist mein besuch aber nicht die können
sie mehr darüber
und andere ist auch wo gemeinsam ist
auch im kleiderschrank sich also
weiter auf diese internierten mittlere
drittel und der hälfte
auch wenn christian praktisch alles
selber erledigen will und kann nimmt
einen solchen situationen gerne hilfe an
was man christian aber nicht ansieht
sind die schmerzen die er wie die
meisten paraplegiker empfindet
die smartphone kunden dafür dass haben
sich gut vorstellen werden wo drückt was
den anfang rebele wohl auch keine sich
am tag x wird gerne sei und sich nicht
in schmerz wie wenn wir
den schmerz nicht mehr den schmerz
vorstellen wenn ich wenn ich mich mal
mit ausschlagen oder so
akut wo was auch und sondern
sensation oder orientalisch es war ein
wenn man sich darauf konzentriert immer
stärker wird immer stärker weil man halt
immer mehr weiter voll wahrnimmt der 8
und das völlig siege hab ich meine wenn
man da los war das haben das permanent
präsent ist und sich als total ausland
also der automatischen dem ich mich
weder besonders konzentrieren das
ist das beste
abschalten kann er beim sport wie hier
auf sardinien mit seinem nagelneuen
trainings bike
[Musik]
gibt es irgendwelche ganz sage okay die
wir die netze fahrweg staat
also uns das passiert wunderbaren ich
nicht aber das ist natürlich sind
grenzen gesetzt aber ich probiere
natürlich ganz
ruhig weiß ich auch möglichkeit dazu
meint etwa max lauer schranken setzen
und die muss ich akzeptiere es geht
meint dass ich wäre glücklich wenn ich
würde wetten auf steigende und wird
stärker im fokus ist einfach nicht da
sowieso landtag und fertig also dass sie
einfach ganze die habe ich aber nicht
verstehe aber es gibt kein drama und das
sind ja die interessante die bewegliche
grenzen und drummer haben für sich
möglichkeit den slot und das beim erich
hand
die gibt es im alltag zu hause dann ist
flexible improvisation angesagt
euro
[Applaus]
das mehrere tausend franken teure bike
obwohl auf ihn maßgeschneidert passt
noch nicht
[Musik]
neben pflege
doch dann klappt es und die erste
trainingsfahrt kann losgehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du bist vorher auf das
so bin ich eigentlich drucken ist
geändert oder durch knicks dass ich
eigentlich so mit dem namen stütze ist
also in vereinen und wenn ich jetzt frei
wird sitzt dann ist ein ballon sorgt der
musik also zieht an die der luft aber
jetzt braucht die reine schöpfen denn
unter machen hat das könnte ich nie frei
von drei oder rehabilitation kurz nach
der attacke das nicht jetzt und ich
eigentlich relativ wenig schlaf ihr
spiel und so kann ich ebenfalls relativ
gut aber wenn ich die 1000 lehrerinnen
immer ausgleichen mit der andere sieht
damit die notbremse streitpunkt das
immer gerne stehen wenn ich sage klipp
ich habe und ziemlich bevor
gemeindekasse wieder einfach da ich
ziehe mich auf seehofers klettern so ist
wie wenn ich das es im fußball mache
aber das mache ich nicht so richtig zoff
und wenn ihr los leider keine wie drüben
haben
sind ich mache alles mit einem und da
sich ja eigentlich verbuchen
rückenmuskeln buch das ich ja eigentlich
nicht vorne amerika das gar nicht wie
oft
ich
kann mir das mal wenn ich heute bisher
so lobt war habe ich mit der hand gegen
warum ich mir sehr fest damit damit die
nicht ist übergewicht com nachfragen
oder nicht und da schon immer gesagt ich
kann nicht mit beide handelspartner und
lockt das berichtet das
besteuerungsrecht und das
großes handicap im rollstuhl wir
kontrollieren immer sondern sind auch
lesen das war mal
besprechung der tagestour als
cheftrainer geht christian auf die
bedürfnisse seiner athleten ein
schlafender macht sind 111 kilometer
waren dass man also kredite hat man
maximal
240 für dich kein problem zum waren
sieben stunden dadurch oder
stoßen
und markus wirtschaft also braucht man
schon wenn man dir und begaben die
organisation ist eines doch was es mit
den natürlichen bedürfnissen auf einer
langen tour mit der blase dass ich
glaubte teil ist jeder widerrechtlich an
der stabilität die chemiker konnte uns
kategorisieren das ist so die einteiler
machen sie immer die anderen auch das
nicht ganz so intermittierende andere
immer es ist den ich mach euch zum
beispiel lang auf
lokalen jahr weiß das ist mir jetzt
haben wir alle da mache ich mir lagen
flug vielleicht einmal der ganze
qualität aber so ist das sagen okay wenn
halter des untergrunds und dann schiebt
sich mini lag also unterschreibt ist
nicht der ältere leute immer sagen
irgendwann wiedersehen conti nahmen vor
allem für die älteren normal stoff oder
wald wo man natürlich welche tabu ist
immer noch wo man sich jetzt gehalt ist
auf die jagd zu ihre und da ich meine
wieso sollte ich mir die patientin die
auch durch klärt uns einfach das
austoben also für mich ist das völlig
normal wenn sie auch einmal situationen
gibt und ich mach ich das
kantonsspital luzern seit eineinviertel
jahren arbeitet christian als
assistenzarzt auf der medizinischen
abteilung
hiermit herren und lernen verletzten
patienten
für seine sportlichen einsätze kann er
dieses jahr unbezahlten urlaub nehmen
einschränkungen gibt es für christian
wegen seines rollstuhls im praxisalltag
praktisch keine
[Musik]
das ganzes bald ganze bayerische kritik
auf der linken nach einem sturz
schmerzendes knie kann er einwandfrei
untersuchen
druck
stehen
was macht
das bleiben sagt sie es ist
ganz klar
das macht hinterher sagen
okay
chefarzt visite christian informiert den
leiter der neurorehabilitation über
seine patienten und bespricht den
weiteren verlauf
die elbe ziehen als arzt ich finde ihn
toll
aktiv und ich natürlich auch ganzen
tollen arzt auf der rehabilitation für
patienten das geht natürlich sehr viel
glaubwürdigkeit auch für patienten mit
ihrem problem wo eben auch mit
behinderung für euch sind
mit höherem eine
ziemlich geil
ich muss ich noch voll unterstützt
ich bin so stolz
naja
im trainingslager auf sardinien stößt
der cheftrainer schon mal an grenzen
herausforderungen den motivieren
fahrten mit geschwindigkeiten von bergab
bis zu 80 stundenkilometer lassen uns
vergessen dass hier paraplegiker im bike
sitzen
wollte
auch wenn christian konditionell noch
nicht der stärkste ist will er immer
vorne mithalten durchbeißen
ja ja
[Musik]
auch das indoor training gehört zur
seriösen wettkampfvorbereitung
wer an die paralympics reisen darf muss
sich zuerst dafür qualifizieren
markus rabe ist seit einem motocross
unfall vor zehn jahren im rollstuhl
lukas weber stürzte vor neun jahren beim
ganz normalen velo fahren und ist
seither gelähmt
markus raupach lukas weber sind die
beiden hoffnungsvollsten anwärter dieser
trainingsgruppe für die paralympics
[Applaus]
das ist ihr serien zielorientiert
leistungsorientiert
mensch bist du also nein
eigentlich
eine spitzenquote glauben aber
dass irgendwie mit oder ich bin
so zielorientiert aber sehr
diszipliniert sagen wir mal ein großer
nachteil ich sehe extrem aktiv wurde er
macht sehr viel
ist sicher gut
die jung und
das schlachten sind also machen sie die
energie und das machen und das wirkt und
dann
danke euch eigentlich nicht das macht es
so oder so nicht gemacht ist hast du dir
die behinderung akzeptiert
man geschmack
des getränks
kongo und eine schiene ist auch sehr gut
und ich sehe da und sich aktiv darum zu
drucken damit zu tun ich habe
die musik hören
im rollstuhl in
der früh zwar schon verschrieben und
jetzt eben das im moment
darum herum passiert vieles schöne sache
wahrscheinlich aus vorausgegangen
man muss einfach morgens noch als
positiver osnabrücker die schön dass
auch unsere versuche
die großen ganzen
plusminus
als student die wellen hoch zitiert
ich habe 20 personen wurden
stört das geschenk bin
[Musik]
ich weiß eigentlich was es bedeutet wenn
er sagt das heks akzeptiert das ist
positiv ranking und
peking ist noch ein weiter weg
doch diese männer wollen hoch hinaus da
muss das privatleben hinten anstehen
christians zeitintensive aktivitäten
sind keine einfache belastungsprobe für
das frisch verliebte paar darum nutzen
die beiden jede minute die ihnen
zusammen bleibt ein junges attraktives
paar da darf auch die sexualität nicht
fehlen wie können die beiden diese
lieben
was ihm wichtig ist und darum ist das
ist das nicht anders
grundsätzlich funktioniert habe mir
alles normal
im körper alles gesund und ganz das was
sich viele fans vorstellen er sich bloß
neuester streich auf der relativ oder
brust bei mir auf die eier höre ich sind
unterbrochen
sprich also ich wäre kein vertrag
zwischen ohne und
funktionen ist eigentlich vor allem
normalen ungestört bewusst und das seit
tagen wird funktionen vor der sexualität
spricht erektion ist normal möglich aber
nur durch das dass ich mir das
vorstellen oder bis 10 mg erregt die
daten sind sondern durch direkte
mechanische bericht zum beispiel und
dass ich anders und natürlich dass ich
es nicht spüren also wenig gespürt
weil schüler und brauchen ist ein
bericht mit dem
das ist für mich eigentlich ganz
wesentlich ist ein krieg wo wehtut
allerdings weiß ich doch dass ich mich
um falschparker lag dann sehr genau wie
sich das auf nicht unterschätzen ich war
nicht wirklich
weiß genau wie sich das nach so vielen
situationen sehr gute gedanken und darum
finden und das ist wohl nicht mehr guten
vorstellung wahrscheinlich nicht
vorstellig nicht angesagt träumen und
träume wie sie richtig und wo was ich
einfach nicht
[Musik]
fast ebenso wichtig wie die liebe ist
für christian die musik
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie schicken wir gemerkt dass das mein
ich länger nicht spielt das merkt er
dass ich das nie möglich ausgleicht
bisher ich habe das nicht erklären sich
für mich musik ist der zugang zu dem
optionen
im inneren und
wenn ich musik spielen kann ich durchaus
mal brüderle das mit drei nach emmental
tatsächlich sehr intensive gefühle
empfindet und das passiert mir ist
eigentlich
meine songs das hochgefühl und
das immer so jetzt geht das hat man aber
immer mit dem bypass aber fahrt und die
freiheit dass die unfreiheit spürt oder
sowas ist aber das nicht wirklich spaß
ganze andrea bin ich also das ist doch
verrückt wahrscheinlichkeit für mich
musik bedeutet überhaupt über hofelich
einfachen
zugang zu musik ich glaube nicht dass
nicht auch der zugang nicht aus sondern
hat sorgen vielleicht hat besonderen
wollen wichtige
musik hat im elternhaus immer eine
wichtige rolle gespielt die eltern
spielen seit vielen jahren in diversen
orchestern
die schwester ist berufsmusikerin die
musik war es auch die die familie nach
dem unfall näher zusammengebracht hat
alle haben christian dabei unterstützt
seine musikalische karriere
voranzutreiben
das kkl in luzern
kaum zu glauben aber wahr im januar 2006
darf christian im besten konzertsaal der
schweiz seinen größten musikalischen
erfolg mit einem klavierkonzert von
krieg feiern eine hydraulische
spezialkonstruktion erlaubt es ihm das
fußpedal einzusetzen indem er auf ein
röhrchen beißt stadt mit dem fuß das
pedal zu drücken
[Musik]
im paraplegikerzentrum nottwil trifft
sich christian mit dem klinikdirektor
billiger er strebt eine anstellung als
oberarzt am paraplegiker-zentrum an
ab januar 2009 wird er voraussichtlich
hier arbeiten ich möchte aus betroffene
sagt jetzt position und ich verantworte
kann über
mich wissen dahin zurückbringen zum zum
patient
der situation noch nicht so prall abda
ich glaube dass das eine große chance
für patienten klar für dieses team
im team ist ja gut wenn ich gleich einer
der roboter so viel wie ist dass die
spezifische
ich sage mal beschwerden sind oder diese
spezifische wünsche
es nicht gleich autonomie im zentrum
stöhnt unter der sache natürlich
überbringen will er das bild gemacht hat
ein weiterer grund für den besuch in
nottwil ist seine große handbike
hoffnung markus hauber der athlet ist
wenige wochen nach dem trainingslager
daheim auf einer gemütlichen ausfahrt
mit seinem bike in eine hausmauer
gefahren hat mehrere kopfverletzungen
erlitten und seine rechte schulter
zertrümmert aus der traum von peking
es ist
das beste los nur models bei
den chefs willkommen
da
kannst du das letzte
die hand operiert werden ganz montenegro
wird
ist totaler trainer braucht immer
fraktur muss
händisch muskulatur
muskulatur im
schnitt gemacht da profitieren weil es
kommt zu noch zeigt
dass sich das zwiebelprinzip aleker das
heißt sie sind vorher gar nicht zu kurz
um das ganze richtig zuhören und das
royal society vor
klar
der
nächste
abgang atomkritischen markus yahoo also
selbst im märz erst einmal der ob sagt
burkard stabil bleibt und dann das erste
und je nach unternehmen steht aber der
anteil der gedanke
was heißt dass physisch das heißt dass
verzögerung das heißt das für
den sport mit dem umfang das sind alles
für träume zerbrochen da
meine das ist ja nicht nur die verletzte
schulter sondern ganz viel mit zusammen
und extrem gut mit viel weil ich
am anfang wurde ich häufig ziel kam
realistisch
und weiß genau was einem abgeordneten
moment markus das göttinger
forschungsprojekt
sind wie
muss ich sagen
mehr methan als
chaotisch und jetzt trag
junioren
probiert oder
sie betrieb
gedruckt und ausgesteuerte
muttersprache ist noch nicht gesprochen
liga schon mit nur 1 euro krise
ja ich will dich bestimmt weiter rasch
mit einem
missklang selben revanche genommen
transferieren
das ist
völlig stand
extrem lange stück
[Musik]
trägt was das leben extrem
vor wenigen wochen haben in der schweiz
die letzten selektionsrennen
stattgefunden ohne markus rauber
[Musik]
für die paralympics in peking haben sich
die erfolgreichsten handbiker
qualifiziert franz möglichst auch der
bisher 14 mal gold gewonnen hat
ebenso mit dabei ist heinz frey
zweifache goldmedaillengewinner an den
sommerspielen
[Musik]
als einzige frau reist ursula schwaller
im handbike team mit
und auch für lukas weber geht der traum
von der teilnahme an den paralympics in
erfüllung
doch christian trend bereits weiter in
vier jahren will er an den paralympics
in london selber mit an den start
[Musik]
christian wenk ein junger mann der
niemals aufgibt und immer wieder gewinnt
auch in der liebe lacht ihm das glück
und vermehrt sich schon einige skandale
letzter zeit ständig und und
schon nicht nur
für mich plötzlich irgendwie sieht wie
sie doch meinen und wenn es als wochen
ist also wenn sie jetzt sehr gern kocht
und zweitens macht dass ich
irgendwo ich bin einfach mal gibt sie in
allen
und irgendwo gab dir das nicht wenn man
auch zusammen wohnt und
vor dem heimischen um stelle ich sie
sind beide mit der unglücklich ja es ist
immer noch
[Musik]